[Music]
hallo YouTube chaste lovers and my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the 20th episode of dirty tricks in
this episode I am going to show you some
of the wonderful tricks in the Italian
la borderless variation from the black
perspective the Italian game arises
after the Mordor efore ePHI Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 and now the
move Bishop to c5
now instead of Bishop to c5 in my 10th
episode of dirty chess tricks I have
covered the Moon Knight to f6 which
leads to the Trexler counter-attack so
if you are attacking clear and you're
looking for a tremendous attacking line
then you should certainly look out for
that video after the move Bishop to c5
if you check the mega database or any
live book you are going to find out the
main move over here is the c3 now apart
from c3 white can also castle on the
Kings side and then place the c3 but
more or less it comes to the same story
the big idea after the move c3 is white
wants to expand with the move d4 and
grab the center quickly in the opening
and that's why the main move over here
is Knight to f6 which immediately
pressurizing the e4 square and somehow
preventing the move d4 but as usual I'm
going to recommend you something very
tricky and here in this position instead
of the Moon Knight to f6 I propose you
should continue with the MU d6 which at
first sight looks very horrible because
black is not pressurizing the e4 square
and that means I can straightforwardly
grab the center with the move d4 but
believe it or not this is exactly black
ones now apart form d4 but can also play
the castle and then play the d4 which
leads to the same variation the only
thing which I am not covered
in this lecture that is the mood III
known as modern Italian game so you need
to go through the theory section and
find out a reputa against that line okay
let's see what's the big idea after
white plays the obvious move deform
well here black should certainly capture
this pawn and after pawn captures and
Bishop to b6 at first sight it looks
like why it has a wonderful Center but
if you closely look at it right now
these two pieces are attacking the d4
and if white is not careful then Bishop
to g4 comes into the mix and sooner or
later White has to give up the center or
push this pawn which will not create a
pleasant scenario for the white once
again if we check the mega database or
live book you are going to find that in
almost all the to na means more than 70%
of the people has played the MU H 3 and
it is very logical because that way what
is stopping the move Bishop to g4 but
here black reveal history after the move
Knight to f6 well it's very funny that
at first sight it looks like White has a
problem with d4 but now black has really
tricked the wide and shows that the real
problem exists on the efore square here
white has mainly tried the 3 apply
amongst them Aoife is the worst of all
because after the simple reply D
captures ePHI no matter however white
recapture is going to be the material
town so for example if D captures Aoife
then after Queen captures King captures
and the move Knight to e4 white is
simply going to lose upon
so that means ePHI is not possible at
this point let's look at other two
replies the first move I want to
consider over here is Knight to c3 when
after this black has distressed links
sacrifice Knight captures e5
now as I highlighted over here white has
few choices amongst them Castle is the
main move but apart from the castle we
should see what will happen if white
plays other moves for example here if
Bishop captures f7 then the simplest is
you capture this bishop and after Knight
captures efore you play the move rook to
e8 so pinning that night obviously white
can escape from the pin via the MU
castle the idea is if you play the move
rook captures efore then Knight to g5
will NAB the exchange so obviously we
are not going to fall for that but
instead of that black has a better move
that is King to g8 and now this is the
pretty much situation you are going to
see in most of the scenario so what
actually happened in all of this line is
black will get this bishop pair and
White has this isolated D pawn which
will be the target for the rest of the
game so it's a kind of positional trick
where first of all black create a
weakness in the white camp and then
black try to exploit that weakness
throughout the game now to illustrate
this I like to show you some games in
this line here my opponent who is 1700
rated he continued with the Moon Knight
to g5 so his idea is to play the move
Queen to b3 but then blacks one reply
defy and White is in a serious trouble
my opponent continue with his tricky
journey by playing the move Queen to d3
I had applied with the MU g6 and now
black has a simple threat of Bishop to
Fr and then at 6 and navigli Knight so
after a long thought my opponent
continued here with the move Knight to
even so he just want to release the
space for the night
but doing so he forgot that white deep
one Hanks and after the continuation
that is Bishop to a5 Queen to d1 and
night to d4 not only black is ahead in
material but look at the black pieces
they are far ahead in the development so
Bishop to f7 doesn't work very well the
second option
what can try over here is Knight
captures efore but then black will
regain his piece after the movie file
now here if White Castle or play the
move Bishop to g5 then it will transpose
to the line which we are going to look
at at the later part so the biggest
mission arise is what black should do
after white capture this pawn well after
Bishop captures that you'd certainly
capture this piece and after the move
Knight to c3 and Queen to c4 now you can
see the dark side of the whole
transaction as I mentioned earlier not
only White has created a deadly weakness
on his cam but at this point white
cannot castle on the Kings side this is
a cause of my game against 1988 opponent
where he continued with the critical
move defy I responded with the move
Knight to b4 so there is a threat of
Knight to d3 check my opponent buried
with the moon Knight to e5 also hitting
my queen I responded with the move Queen
to d4 so now black has some severe
threats the main threat is Queen
captures f2 with a checkmate and also
black is hitting this week night kindly
note if black at this point plays moves
such as Queen to eat or castle on the
King side then black can continue with
the castle on the King side and in those
position black always obtain a slight
advantage so in this game my opponent
continued with the move Queen to a4
check I replied with the Moose c6 and
now the black threat remain as it is so
my opponent continued with the MU castle
on the King side so it's tactical idea
is if I capture this piece then my own
Hanks but here I played a very strong
move that is night captures defy and now
black is a simple point of where white
doesn't have a single compensation okay
let's look at the most critical reply
that is castle on the kingside now
Castle creates the last year idea that
if black foolishly captured this night
then loop to even create some
devastation on the black King side but
of course black is not going to fall for
that and here black has a better move
that is castle on the King side so at
this point black is a clear pawn up so
that's why white is forced to capture
this piece afterwards
we are going to continue with the more
defy now practically there are three
good replies exist over here amongst
them Bishop to d3 is a vast one because
after pawn captures Bishop captures and
Knight captures black is simply upon up
so that's not good if Bishop captures
defy at this point which is somewhat
better than the last line because he or
White has already castle on the Kings
side but nevertheless black will
continue with them Queen captures and
after Knight to c3 and Queen to d6 we
obtain our same pattern that is we get
bishop pair and White has a loose target
on the default now here if white
continue with the passive move such as
Bishop to e3 then in those cases black
will continue with the move Bishop to a5
and then rope comes on the D file and
slowly building a pressure on the D pawn
so that means White has to play somewhat
active in this position the only
critical reply over here is D Phi and
after that I am suggesting you should
play the move Knight to e7 now it's all
good to say we have a bishop pan White
has a isolated pawn but the big question
is how you going to exploit this so to
give you this answer I like to show you
one of my game where my opponent was W I
am rated around 2300 at this point she
continued with the move rook to e1
I continue with the move Bishop to d7
and she played the most aggressive move
that is Bishop to g5 attacking the
knight
I defended with the rook 88 and now she
revealed his nasty plan that is Knight
to e4 after some calculation I accept
this challenge and played the Queen
captures d fire my opponent idea was she
wants to play the moon Bishop captures
e7 so now the Queen is hanging so black
is forced to exchange the Queen that his
Queen captures d1 but then white has
this wonderful reply night to have sex
check now instead of Knight to f6 check
rook captures d1 leads to the same
position that Knight to f6 looks
somewhat flashing here black doesn't
have any good choice black has to accept
this peace afterwards white reveal his
nasty idea that is rook after Steven so
right now white is attacking two species
that is rook on the f8 and Bishop on d7
that means black responds his force
black has to give up the exchange rook
captures e7 and after rook captures c7
at first glance it looks like black is a
simple exchange down with not enough
compensation and I think she has only
calculated up till this far but after
blacks next reply that is Bishop to e6
it turns out that white rook is not
going anywhere hear my opponent gone
into the deep thought and finally she
come up with the moon
g4 I responded with the move rook to c8
so protecting the pawn my opponents
bonded with the MU G Phi so her idea was
if I played King f8 then pawn captures
is good for white but instead of that I
played a stronger move that is came to
g7 she played h4 I capture the pawn now
here if Knight to g5 then rook to g8 is
a very strong reply so I decided to play
H captures g5 but that allows Bishop to
c5
now what is forced to give up the
exchange so rope captures pawn captures
and if you look at this position not
only black emerge with an extra pawn but
it's easy to play as a black where on
the counter part white doesn't have
enough compensation after few moves I
managed to win this game the third
tricky move I can try over here is
Bishop to g5 which has a very sneaky
idea that if you foolishly play over
here the move epps ik's then after
Bishop captures pawn captures and Bishop
to b3 white obtained advantage due to
the shattered pawn structure on the
black King side so here instead of f6
black has a better move that is Queen to
d7 more or less force white to give up
the piece back after Bishop captures
defy and Queen captures defy black is
attacking the knight so Knight to c3 and
now here I'm recommending you should
play the Queen to fi now once again
Bishop to e3 leads to the easiest
position for the black so the only
critical reply over here is D Phi
afterwards I'm recommending black should
continue with the move Knight to e5
attacking the knight and after Knight
captures Queen captures Bishop Knight to
f3 and Queen to g6 I think these
positions are very easy to play as a
black s Black has a wonderful bishop
pair looking at the White King side and
don't forget this evergreen weakness on
the d5 square I got this position
against a feed a master and I have
included the whole game in the PGN which
is available in the description so
kindly go through the PGN the third and
the final move white can try over here
is castle on the King side against it
where you can play the move Knight
captures efore but I will prefer the
castle first the reason is it give more
option to white go wrong now there are
mainly three plus
try by the white amongst them if you
open and place the Moon Knight to c3
then after Knight captures efore we
transpose to the line which we have
already gone through and the second move
that is Bishop to g5 which is amazingly
enough even higher ranked player has
tried it but in this position it is
outright mistake the simple reason is
after at six
no matter however white plays his
position is not good so for example if
Bishop captures f6 then the simplest is
you capture with the Queen and now the
d4 pawn hangs and if white foolish
enough to play the Moody Phi then after
Queen captures attacking the rook Knight
to d2 and the move Knight to d4 black
simply emerge with an extra pawn now
instead of Bishop captures f6 what
happens if Bishop to h4 well here black
and seriously create problems for the
white after the muchif I kindly note if
Bishop to g3 at this point then after
Knight captures efore black again simply
a pawn up and if white goes with the
tactical line that is Knight captures G
file
hoping to gain some attack on the King
side well it's just a fake imagination
because after pawn captures and Bishop
captures black and simply capture the d4
pawn and not only it's attacking the b2
square but black can simply defend his
King side with the moves such as King to
g7 droop to h8 and in fact it is black
who is having all the fun in this line
the third and the main move at this
position is rook - even afterwards we
are going with our same strategy that is
Knight captures e4 here why doesn't have
any options white has to accept this
piece afterwards we are going to play
the Moody file now the whole complex of
the lines we have seen so far amongst
them
this line is the most accurate by the
white although white loses his bishop
pair white gains some sort of initiative
after the Moon Knight
see three but no matter black is already
equalized and after the move Queen to d8
why it has the only move which keep his
initiative that is the move D file here
I am recommending you should play the
move Knight to e7 and it is amazing that
after Knight captures e4 we get such a
lovely position where black has a bishop
pair and there is an isolated D pawn
which give enough counter to the black
now to illustrate this I like to show
you my game against a feed a master on
which will highlight how you should
continue from here onwards hear my
opponent continue with the move Bishop
to g5 so attacking the knight here I
responded with the mu Epsilon and played
the move Bishop to f4 I developed my
last piece with the move Bishop to fi my
opponent plays rook to e2 and now I
reroute my Bishop with the move Bishop
to g6 at this point my opponent grabbed
the opportunity to dissolve his weak
pawn with the move d6 and this is the
strength of a good player he knows that
he has a weakness and he is just get rid
of this witness at the right time no
matter I continue with the moves C
captures d6 my opponent capture with the
bishop so at first sight it looks very
scary but in the long run it's a good
for black I calmly play over here rook
to e8 getting out of the beam my
opponent give me this check and I played
Bishop to f7 and now his idea is to play
the move Queen to a3 well so far White's
plays very energetic but now his attack
is running out of the fuel and now it is
black who is going to show what actually
attack means here I continue with the
move Knight to f5 attacking the bishop
my opponent captured the rook I capture
with the Queen and his idea is to gain a
tempo in the queen with the Mook to even
no matter I continue with the move Queen
to c6 and now that Bishop has to move in
the game my opponent decided to play
Bishop to a4 but it turns out that this
is a big time mistake
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out what is the
wrong with the move Bishop to f4
okay I hope you find this wonderful
continuation which in my game I found
out after a very depth calculation the
move is G Phi attacking the bishop and
after the move Bishop to H to black has
this dazzling moon Bishop captures have
to BAM ha ha ha so why doesn't have any
good choices white has to accept this
and after King captures f to black
reveal his cunning idea with the Queen
check the problem is after King to e2
and rope to d8 this King is going to
check mated in the next move with the
Bishop to c4 so why it has to stop it my
opponent played the only reply that is
b3 stopping Bishop to c4 but then he has
to face Queen check King to have fun and
now Queen captures c3 when after the
whole sequence it turns out that it is
black who is having the great advantage
my opponent continued his aggression
with the move Queen captures a7 I
responded with the move Bishop to defy
he played Queen to b6 attacking my rook
I simply drop back to the a it where it
is attacking one a2 and now my opponent
finally decided to retrieve his Queen in
the defense of a to pawn as well as the
king now here of course black has so
many good moves but I decided to play
this sequence that is Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures pawn
captures and now rook captures and I was
damn sure that this is completely
waiting for the black the rook is
attacking bishop my opponent played
Bishop to c7 I attack one more time with
the move rook to c2
he played Bishop to e5 but after King to
seven King to g1 and now the Moon Knight
to d4
White is about to lose his second pawn
and there is nothing he can do about it
my opponent replied with the MOOC to
have fun but after Knight captures b3 he
simply realized that there is no point
of playing this game father that's it
guys I hope with this brief analysis you
are confident enough to include this
secret weapon in your chess recruiter
kindly go through the PGN where I have
shown some line in detail once again
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care
doing your best again obviously I'm in
doing you and your best means doing your
best and I don't know why you don't
understand English have you ever
imagined that none of your piece comes
out in the board and still you are
creating a trap that sounds like
impossible right but that is exactly the
situation is over here